[Musique]
oui mais voilà d'acton spécial visite du
pape j'ai encore en vacances pour
quelques semaines mais vous comprendrez
qu'avec une visite de cette ampleur
l'impact surtout la
symbolique historique de ce que c'est on
ne pouvait pas pas m'exprimer sur la
question un peu essayé de partager un
petit peu ce qui s'en vient parce qu'il
ya beaucoup question qui se flatte dans
les heures non seulement des l'apport de
personnes allochtone mais aussi tout ce
qu'on voit de mobilisation autour des
communautés autochtones énormément de
personnes de différentes communautés
vont essayer de se rendre là où le pape
sera présent
edmonton iqaluit et québec à la
basilique sainte anne de beaupré
écoutez pour quelqu'un qui nous qui a
été élevé dans la religion catholique
qui a eu le passé que vous pouvez
imaginer la religion catholique
le 28 juillet c'est quand même tout près
et collé sur le 26 juillet qui est une
des célébrations les plus importantes du
calendrier
chez les premières nations mais surtout
chez des in ou parce que c'est la fête
de sainte anne de beaupré de la grand
mère de jésus ce qui ne célébrait sont
extrêmement importantes et d'ailleurs il
souvent pèlerinage qui se fait à sainte
anne de beaupré pour l'occasion donc il
devrait y avoir déjà quand même beaucoup
de personnes présentes qui sont
autochtone mais là on va avoir une
convergence de vues communauté se
rendent jusqu'à 50 de vos prix se rend
jusqu'à 50 c'est encore drôle parce
qu'il va y avoir quand même beaucoup de
sécurité ceux qui ont plus à voir
quelques-uns des billets qui étaient mis
en disponibilité pour être à la
basilique ont été vendus en quelques
minutes seulement mais on va voir des
excités comme je pense beaucoup à la
marche qui se fait présentement site est
en train de s'organiser et probablement
et déjà
branle-bas qui va partir de l'ancien
pensionnat justement de match terrible
et qui vont marcher jusqu'à sainte anne
de beaupré je pense à énormément de gens
qui vont aller à différents endroits
pour pouvoir trouver non seulement des
réponses mais pour d'autres ça va être
des moments de guérison de procès rome
jusqu'au pape pour certains ça va être
des protestations où est l'argent qu'on
doit donner ou survivants des
pensionnats que l'église sport josé
mérite d'amuser araignée un mec qui ont
trouvé 30 millions pour faire venir le
pape donc vous allez voir et entendre
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de différents
angles et c'est ce qui m'inquiète le
plus ce mode dans cette visite le c est
encore un grand mystère autour des
enjeux qui concernent des premières
nations les personnes inuit les
personnes meti et la relation avec
l'église catholique parce que ce que
j'en passe sont assez véloce avec tout
ce qu'ils auront enfin comment de ce
qu'ils vont voir le pape qui veulent
voir sa visite est bien c'est que faut
pas oublier que historiquement pas
toutes les générations étaient au
pensionnat je pense beaucoup à ma
communauté ou est-ce que
la génération de nos grands parents ou
arrières grands parents eux ont pas été
aux français mais la génération de nos
parents nos oncles ou tantes eux ils ont
été vous pouvez imaginer que ça fait
deux vécu très différents et de
réception très différente face à
l'église je donne un exemple
j'en aurais beaucoup des choses à dire
avec beaucoup de colère beaucoup de la
haine en bouteille
et sans vouloir généraliser sur tout les
grisons s'entend parce que ce serait la
même chose que de généraliser sur les
programmations sur les autochtones le 20
mai la grande gloire de cette
institution là
je peux pas l'exprimer aussi librement
que je voudrais pas ce que par respect
pour mes grands parents par exemple
il ya des gens qui eux ont tourné
complètement de l église rien savoir je
suis un peu parti qui aurait préféré ne
pas avoir à vivre cette compassion là
avec le pape avec comment la réception
du canada va être parce que on va on
parle de la réception des communautés
autochtones on parle pas la réception
des canadiens qui eux n'ont pas eu un
historique des pansements et j'exclus
bien sûr toutes celles et ceux qui on
est et on s'entend avec les orphelins du
plessis et qui ont eu leur propre
histoire mais la majorité parce que on
s'entend que nous notre historique a été
ignorée aussi par la majorité attend la
visite avec quand même beaucoup
d'intérêt ou curiosité donc il va y
avoir un espèce de
de dissonance entre certaines stars et
on voit on va voir peut-être déjà les
communautés autochtones qui sont
extrêmement content de voir le pape qui
vont faire des cadeaux et y la réception
que ça va être pour ceux qui n'ont pas
le cadeau eux les livres d'école
résidentiel réponde à ça et être en
colère donc on va voir aussi même un
mélange d'émotions non seulement qu'ils
vont diverger entre communautés
autochtones communauté adaptable aux
séances les communautés autochtones même
dans les communautés à il va y avoir une
annonce donc c'est pour ça que je
voulais faire cette chronique déjà pour
garder les gens ouverts face à ce qu'ils
vont découvrir sur les pensionnats pas
ce qu'est ce qu'ils vont découvrir sur
la relation qui est encore présidente
est très vive pour certains avec
l'église catholique
car ils ont quand même été responsables
de 60% des pensionnats par le passé
on va entendre les excuses du pape on
s'entend que c'est probablement un des
peuples les plus progressistes de
l'histoire de la papauté mais faut pas
oublier non plus que le pape comme les
autres organismes à travers la planète
les autres visions dans la planète
représente un individu à travers une
institution qui est très solide et très
riche dont vous êtes peut-être entendre
les questions sur est ce qu'on va voir
toutes les dossier est ce qu'on va
ravoir les artefacts et les mises en
garde et est-ce qu'on va avoir
des excuses ou où ça va être juste une
seule fois alors que l'impact et annuels
pour nous tu es donc est-ce qu'il va
avoir des cérémonies des commémorations
qui vont se faire est ce que l'église
pourrait présenter annuellement
des excuses on le sait pas il aura aussi
entendre
la réponse que le retour de manivelle
bello qui en viennent moi j'y crois pas
au pensionnat ils font juste ça pour
avoir l'argent vous allez entendre tout
seul donc pourquoi je fais c'est très
vite en avant de la visite c'est pour se
garder ouverts se garder alerte face à
ce que les pans les anciens
pensionnaires vont vivre et aussi pour
garder notre
notre ont choisi
notre opinion en alerte par rapport aux
c'est ce qu'ils vont en support de la
part du grand public donc
vous comprendrez c'est très émotionnel
c'est très
[Musique]
ça va être une période qui va éveiller
chez beaucoup de gens beaucoup de choses
des histoires qui sont sortis pendant la
commission vérité réconciliation qui ont
été entendus par ceux qui ont témoigné
ceux qui ont vu commission vérité et
réconciliation pour peut-être en fait
être entendu parce que le pape est là et
que justement ces historiens vont être
mis face à lui ou peut-être qu'on va
aseptisé sa visite on le sait pas donc
j'espère pouvoir faire une chronique à
100 après la visite pour faire un retour
sur ce que ce qui a été vécu ce qui
était vu sur je dirais aussi l'impact et
salut sur les communautés autochtones et
probablement aussi sur les autres
canadiens qui ont des véhicules
je voudrais en procès avec l'église
catholique donc je vous souhaite une
belle semaine on se voit au retour après
la visite du pape pour essayer de
comprendre ce que cela représentait dans
l'histoire canadienne et pour les
communautés autochtones bonne semaine